limace matin était une ville morte place
vide rue commerçante avec vitrine fermée
alors qu'elles sont normalement noires
de monde on se croirait un dimanche
disent les gens mais déjà très tôt 15000
policiers chiffres records ont pris
place dans les endroits stratégiques ici
devant le Congrès cible prioritaire des
manifestants on ne néglige rien double
barrière et toute la garde mobilisée
pourtant les manifestants sont encore
invisibles ils sont encore ici par
exemple à l'université San Marcos où les
étudiants les ont logés après avoir pris
les locaux d'assaut hier
le mot d'ordre pour la prise de Lima
c'est le nom officiel de la grande
marche c'est un départ à 15h pour se
concentrer sur les places principales du
centre historique
les différentes colonnes sont partis des
quatre coins de la capitale disciplinée
par fois au pas de course écrit à la
démission de la présidente par intérim
Dina bollwarte qualifié d'assassine
d'usurpatrice il réclame la sortie de
prison de l'ex-président toktone Pedro
Castillo
beaucoup de paysans du Sud des Quechua
desaimara on ne sait pas combien sont
venus d'ailleurs 7000 peut-être auquel
s'ajoutent de nombreux habitants de Lima
les revendications dépassent le cadre de
la crise politique et dénonce les
inégalités sociales et économiques on
vend toutes nos ressources 17 femmes il
ne nous reste rien
des barrages de policiers ont bouché
toutes les rues qui mènent soit au
Congrès soit au Palais du gouvernement
les manifestants essaient de les
contourner nous avons assisté à la
première confrontation
[Applaudissements]
un groupe déterminé d'anciens
combattants s'est lancé contre le cordon
policier et a fini par l'enfoncer
des scènes semblables se répètent de
plus en plus de la part de manifestants
frustrés il y a eu des affrontements
violents à Reiki pas qui ont forcé la
fermeture de l'aéroport de grande
manifestations ont encore marqué la
journée à Puno tout le monde n'est pas
parti pour la capitale
une seule sortie de crise est possible
17 parlementaire
dépend de ce que pense mes collègues du
Congrès j'espère qu'il réfléchissent et
que pour retrouver la paix au Pérou ils
disent on s'en va
ce qu'ils ne veulent pas faire pour le
moment pour rien au monde ils ne veulent
perdre leur pouvoir et les avantages qui
viennent avec dans un système totalement
corrompu ensuite
élection générale parlementaire et
présidentielle